everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're gonna continue
our coverage of the 2019 grand prix the
second tournament this one's being held
in a Latvia we are in round one three
days in still in round one that is
because we are on tie breakers this is a
knockout tournament 16 competitors going
head-to-head and a best of two series
and you would expect with chess high
level with 16 players especially in
round 1 there are some tie breakers our
competitors today whites can be played
by topalov currently the 18th ranked
player in the world but he's been around
for a long time he was the world
champion 14 years ago looking to get his
chance to get back on top maybe you can
parlay this into the candidates
tournament he did not play in the first
tournament in the Grand Prix so we will
be playing this one as well as one in
November and December
his opponent playing the blacks places
is the American and Nakamura currently
the 15th ranked player in the world he
did play in the first tournament he
reached to the semi-finals looking to
improve on that in this tournament now
in the first set of the tie breakers
they do play two games those are
25-minute and then they get a ten-second
commit after each move compared to the
normal essentially 2 hours you get 90
minutes and then you get 30 minutes
after move 40 so essentially 2 hours
plus 30 seconds so it's much faster they
play a best of 2 series and then if no
one wins they go to even faster time
controls so we'll go ahead and get into
it with Topalov playing at the white
pieces he starts out with E 4 E 5 and
then f3 knight c6 Bishop b5 and then
Knight to f6 so getting into the Berlin
defense we've seen this very frequently
over the past few years and then we see
to a block play d3 this is pretty common
we also see castle on the kingside so
really doesn't shock me at all just
because this is extremely common at high
level play Bishop down here a c5 upon c3
getting ready push if he wants to on d4
trying to control the center of the
board right here castling kingside
Bishop g5 pinning down this Knight to
the queen pawn to h6
forcing the bishop to come back here
Bishop to e7 and then castle on the King
sad pawn to d6 just solidifying the pawn
chain opening up the door for the
LightSquared Bishop here and then the
bishop comes back here to g3 didn't have
to come back right away you don't really
expect your opponent to be pushing down
here to g5 which would really force that
but decides to want to just bring it
back here it's not really doing too much
here on h4
and it doesn't want to have to deal with
this tonight at some point moving and
then he has his bishop exposed by this
bishop here on e7 ponta a6 forcing the
bishop to come back here to a fourth
pawn at b5 and then the bishop retreats
back here to c2 and usually you see this
win the nights here on c6 because Bishop
b3 Knight to a5 okay now the bishop is
just gonna come back here to see - and
if you don't want your opponent to have
the night here on a5 because maybe later
on he wants to come to c4 if you do try
to push forward here on a d4 may not be
what you're looking to so instead as
table does as many players will do they
just brought their bishop here to see -
nakamura continues with rook to e8 just
centralizing that a little bit more
night to d2 and to blob has completed
his development here Bishop to f8 just
opening up for this rook here on EA to
control a little bit more of the center
of the board since is not being blocked
anymore rook here to e1 same thing on
white side - trying to control the
center with his rooks here Knight to h5
attacking the bishop no real way to
really defend against this decides to
bring his knight down here to f1 after
the exchange if you're just watching
these games for those following along it
almost looked like as soon as he played
this knight here to f1 that he was
immediately just gonna take appear on g3
he had other options and he decided to
use those options and took here with
this pawn on g3 really opening up for
his knight to come to e3 doesn't make a
lot of sense to bring it here to h2
that's not what the game is about but
doesn't want a central like this
centralizes night he does have a nice
little outpost here on f5 as well as d5
so those are some of the
options that he is looking at pawn here
to g6 this does stop one of the outpost
that the knight could eventually come to
on f5 but this is also a little tricky
this is just pushing a little more air
in front of nakamora scheme here so
while is it a good move definitely just
something to keep in mind as Nakamura's
may have to defend a little bit more
than he wants to in front of his king
tonight the e3 as expected Bishop to g7
just being kiddo in this bishop here
trying to attack the center of the board
putting a lot of his defenses his night
here on c6 Bishop here to g7 rook here
on e8 really trying to make sure he
holds on to this e5 a square we talked
about earlier the palm could push
forward here to d4 so wide can at any
time push forward black wants to make
sure that he is prepared for that push
now white moves pawn a 4 and then rook
over here to b8 and that's much better
than the pond taking you always want to
look at what your opponent's gonna do
how they're going to take back and then
what do they have if the pawn takes then
the Bishop's going to recapture here
this rook here on a1 is automatically
activated has a semi-open file and now
he's stuck either defending with his
rook here on a a2 or his bishop here in
c8 neither those is what he wants to be
doing and now there's a very aggressive
bishop here on a4 pinning down the night
there's no other pawns that he can
really use to support this Knight
so either he's gonna have to put his
rook on a really awkward Square or he's
gonna end up losing this Knights right
here and still have to worry about
defending this pawn so it definitely
would be a really terrible move if you
took with this pawn he does not but just
something to keep in mind as you're
playing in your own games barda's rook
here to b8 after the exchange we see the
pond take here now there's an open file
here it doesn't have to worry about the
rook attacking the square right here so
definitely a good way to go about it and
you do want to be taking with your pawn
you don't want to take with your rook
things get really tricky here Bishop to
a4 as we said before it's pinning down
material here so now it's pinning down
the rook to the night here so maybe okay
let's bring the rook to b6 that seems
good in theory but unfortunately after
Knight to c4 this is going to remove
that rook and then the Knights just
going to be hanging out right here so
that's going to be an awful way to
exchange so we do see Nakamura correctly
take with this pawn here on b5 Bishop to
b3 just now attacking this long diagonal
right here also this pawn is being
pinned down so if he ever wanted to push
forward he does have to keep that in
mind because this King is just gonna be
hanging out right here that is one of
the things that black always has to keep
in mind if he plays this pawn up here to
a5 and then wants to support it with
this pawn chain like this is the light
square Bishop does have free rein to
control these light squares rook back to
f8 wants to make sure he holds on to
that material right here and as soon as
the rook moves away from defending the
pawn here on e5 Emelia we see Tokoloshe
come in here and play pawn to d4 I
always want to be looking at what your
opponent's giving up when they move they
may be moving for good reason now to
defend this square but that does also
open up an opportunity and so he
immediately pushes for that opportunity
now pawn to b4 says hey if you want to
go ahead and start chipping away in the
center I'm gonna start chipping away at
your pawn chain as well this pawn over
here is kind of hanging out by himself
the night here on c6 really needs to
move before the pawn can support it and
the knight really needs to hang out here
to hang on to this pawn on e5 so this
pawn completely okay if it does leave by
the wayside Bishop to d5 just
centralizing now attack Knight says you
got to make the move here what are you
gonna do Bishop to d7 says y'all go
ahead and protect that rook to a6 so
just adding more and more oppression
really putting a lot of pressure on
nakamora again these are much quicker
paced games so many times if you can
just put a lot of pressure on your
opponent eventually they will make a
mistake we're just met may not make the
optimal play at any
in time Knight to e7 pawn takes on e5 we
knew eventually that would happen now
that the knight moves here to e7 that's
the exact spot that y decided to go and
push forward you can since that building
since the very beginning of the game
pawn takes back on e5 and then the
bishop comes to c4 pawn takes here pawn
recapture so there is an isolated pawn
for both sides here on the C file but
this Bishop still lying down pinning
down this pawn here on f7 also something
to keep in mind that this rook can come
over here to g6 now it is defended by
the knight on e7
but the pawn can not recapture so at any
time if this Knight were to move then
the rook can easily swing it over and
take here on a g6 really why is that
because the pond cannot recapture
because of the bishop lying down pinning
down that to the King so always be
looking at okay knowing that really that
Knights there so that Knights stock
wants to come to another square but
really just cannot Nakamura realizing
this plays Bishop to c6 blocking off of
the rook from attacking also just
centralizing the bishop attacking the
pawn here on e4 which does not have pawn
support right now and it is defended by
the night here on e7 definitely want to
be defending your minor pieces more than
your king side over here that does have
some weakness Queen to a c2 this does
protect the pawn since doesn't have a
lot of good ways to do that rook to a8
we're going to here to a1 we do see an
exchange similar setup as before but we
do see two rooks come off the board and
then King to h7 just wants to make sure
that his Kings no longer being pinned
down by the by the bishop does give him
some other options if he wants to start
pushing forward on the King side rook to
a5 now wants to start attacking the
center of the board he does have his
night in his rook both attacking it pawn
to f6 as we discussed freely to do that
now that the King's here on 87 so adds
an extra layer extra layer of support
Knight to d2 Queen to d7 and Knight to
b3 so starting to move over to the Queen
side of the board
- a a tonight up here to c5 attack of
the Queen says yeah my Brooke if you
want to Queen - a d6 there is an
exchange on the board Knights to e6 over
really nice square here for the the
knight to be attacked so many of the
squares from Nakamura side and then the
bishop here protecting that pawn to h5
and then Queen down here to be one if
you're looking at and figure you know
why doesn't he take that bishop his
opponent has a bishop pair isn't that a
good thing generally yes and at the
beginning of the game bishop pair is
usually stronger than any other minor
piece combination once you start getting
into the endgame you have to look at
where the pawns are on the board and for
the most part the pawns are on one side
of the board this open or this C file
here with two isolated pawns it's still
pretty close and if it's just one side
of the board where pawns are at Knights
actually tend to do better because they
can control so much of the board if
there's pawn chains on both sides
Bishop tends to do better because they
can get to both sides of the board much
easier so in this case topple off he has
the knight advantage because he has the
double Knights so I would give a slight
edge to white here in this position
Queen to b6 we do see in exchange right
here and then Bishop d5 and this is a
really interesting spot right here lots
of games have interesting setups where
if you're analyzing trying to figure out
you know which side you would take in
this position but really nice move from
top off and just paul's if if you want
to but curious where people would go if
they were black and the reason i think
this is interesting is a lot of
beginners they don't always think about
how long other side's going to recapture
and because of that they end up in a
really tough spot because it seems
pretty reasonable that toe claw has a
good setup here so why not just start
exchanging down especially if you're
nakamura he's better at faster chess so
if we can just draw this game we go -
faster chess he probably is gonna have a
better shot here but if he decides to
take he's gonna be in a world of hurt
the
reason for that is he's gonna recapture
with his pawn and he's gonna have a past
pond and that is absolutely not what you
want to happen here there's just no way
to really stop this he can't recapture
the night can his protecting that so
maybe get his King involved into the
game but the pawns just gonna start
pushing forward again continue to push
forward if the King does come over here
I can just go ahead and clean up here on
d8 yes the knight can take it here but
after the knight takes on d8 watch this
up too much material if we come back and
say what if the bishop doesn't take it
what if the knight takes it's gonna be
similar pawn takes here on d5 the bishop
cannot take here there's just no real
way to stop this if the bishop comes to
b7 you can start to attack it with your
night here met up to see Ford now
threading this material right here
there's just no good way to stop the
pawn from pushing forward so Nakamura
realizing this place correctly and
responds with Bishop to c6 the bishop
takes here
the Knights going to recapture that up
here to d5 attacking the pawn pawn down
to b5 King to f1 now the the Queen's are
off the board we do start to see the
Kings get more and more involved now
Nakamura starts to push on the King side
f5 King here to e2a Bishop h6 and
Knights to a c7 attacking the pawn net
over here to a7 defending it while this
is a good square to defend it this is
not where you want your knife you can
see the tow cloth has two very active
Knights and knock it more over here is
just forced to hang out on the a file
all by himself just defending this pawn
not at all not looking all that great
for knocking more right here the pawn
takes on F 597 you can just hang out
over here wait for his opponent to to
make a mistake because he can just
centralize those Knights very very
quickly pawn to f4 we do see an exchange
right here King to f3 stop in the pond
pawn can't go anywhere the bishop can't
go too many good squares and then we see
an extremely surprising move something
that I would
imagine most people are not gonna expect
and that is Nakamura just giving up his
night and as soon as stop love retook
the night and my guess is there were
some confused faces Nakamura decided to
go ahead and resign out first time you
look at it you may think that the ponds
gonna recapture here on c6 bikes going
the other way that was just Nakamura I'm
not sure if he didn't see the night
exactly why but he just moved and gave
up his night and because of that he is
now out of the tournament so topalov
takes that to game and after they you
know they drew the first one in the
tiebreaker Soto blob will be moving on
Nakamura he is not so not exactly what
he was looking for is going to be very
very difficult for him now to be in the
top two of the entire Grand Prix got in
the semifinals he really needs a lot of
things to go his way but not looking
good right now but congratulations
Topalov played a fantastic game knowing
they didn't play in the first tournament
the grand prix now he wins round one
against a very strong opponent Nakamura
especially in a fast chest which
Nakamura is always gonna be better at
than two Bluff this was a massive win
for him so thank you guys so much for
watching this concludes round one
tomorrow we do start round number two
we'll get back into classical chest as
far as the timing controls and we'll see
who comes out of the final eight
competitors